at his home in a quiet somerset village
colin reeves had been waiting for the
police he just told them he'd stabbed
his neighbors put your hands up
right
hold still
hold still the former army commando had
confessed in a 999 call the neighbour's
been stabbed by who
by me
by you
yes right okay and where are they
are they in their house yes all right
stay on the line for me okay how bad are
the injuries
uh they've been stabbed
several times all right stay on the line
for me okay
stephen and jennifer chapel were lying
dead in their home
their two young sons asleep upstairs
for months reeves had been arguing with
them about parking
on the night of the murder he climbed
the fence into their back garden armed
with a ceremonial dagger he'd been given
when he left the army
neighbors heard screaming as he stabbed
them both several times before climbing
back into his own garden
later in custody he claimed to be
confused giving his name as lance
corporal reeves and describing the
attack as an operation
still my job
he then refused to answer further
questions
how were you involved in their deaths
reeves admitted killing the chapels but
denied it was murder blaming
post-traumatic stress disorder but the
jury took just five hours to convict him
police say it was one of the most brutal
attacks they've ever seen
colin reeves
was fully in control of his actions on
the night of the 21st of november when
he went round to
jennifer and steven's house and decided
that he was going to kill them
the families of the chapels said no
verdict will bring back our beautiful
jennifer and stephen we will now focus
on jennifer and stephen's beautiful boys
helping them to live the life that
jennifer and stephen would have wished
for them
reeves will be sentenced next week for
the murder of a young couple whose
children now face life without them
becky johnson sky news at bristol crown
court